les pompiers s'affairent à noyer les
derniers points chauds ils sont une
soixantaine dépêchés sur l'air de repos
de dijon grognon depuis 8h45 ce matin l'
incendie s'est déclaré dans la partie
restauration du site une zone en travaux
on est sur une surface entre 2500 et
3000 mètres carrés
donc effectivement quasiment entièrement
embrasé comme vous pouvez le constater
dernière moi c'est un bâtiment d'assez
grand volume avec des combles
effectivement qui offrent de grands
volumes de dispersion gaccio ce qui a
favorisé certainement la propagation
rapide de l'incendié aux deux ailes du
bâtiment
les locaux sont partis en fumée mais par
chance aucun blessé n'est à déplorer
les salariés du site ont tous pu être
évacué une cinquantaine de personnes
contraintes ce soir au chômage technique
ça poumon économique ici on a une
cinquantaine de personnes qui
travaillent et qui irrigue son espace
qui hérite tout tout l'espace autour de
la commune
puis basse et des personnes y
travaillent ses revenus aussi pour la
collectivité parce qu'il forte fiscalité
et on le retrouve être en oeuvre pour ce
soir construire rapidement
situé à mi chemin entre le benelux et la
méditerranée l'air de dijon brognon est
très fréquenté sa fermeture qui devrait
durer plusieurs mois est un coup dur
pour la commune à l'aube des vacances
d'été